hello and welcome to this video this is
a bit different because it's not a knife
game the thing is I played a really
really interesting and and a gay game
worth showing just a couple of minutes
ago but I had screwed up the recording
because I simply had my microphone not
plugged in I was not very intelligent
but I saw it near the end of the
recording so I stopped it and I'm now
recording basically a short summary of
the game and it's also nice because I
had a really high rated opponent he has
them as you see here not a very high
rating yet but it's a new accountant it
is I think it is this brand master Andre
se panco I I googled him and he's the
highest rated Russian jr. under 16 he's
I think 15 or something not roughly that
so very he's 2600 already and he really
really give me gave me a proper beating
it's a very new account
he only registered yesterday so the
blitz rating is low but it's it's fully
believable that this is the guy so let's
let's see we had played the petrov and
he played the traditional main line he
would be 45 53 now I played the bishop
to f5 this is a sideline but it is not
not bad castles we should be seven look
one and you know I actually made a
mistake I really played this III just
confused move orders here what I have to
do here is I have to castle first and
wait for one move and see what white is
doing now here white is mostly playing
the move c4 I think this is the most
testing after Knight d2 I dropped back
to d6 and now the bishops were very
likely trained this is a position that I
had on the good
the bird on the board earlier this year
against the Grandmaster in my tournament
in San Sebastian Grandmaster Martinez
from from Cuba and it was a fairly quick
draw after I had equalized completely um
c4 is more is more testing after which
knight c6 is played this has a
reputation of being close to equal I
have not looked at this super super
detailed way and somehow I went this
with this move and this is not so good
as it turned out he really showed nicely
why it is not so great
he took it now he played 93 queen d3 is
probably even stronger but 93 is it's
interesting because I know that I mean I
did a live commentary but I didn't
record it I thought this was a bit odd
because the knight is usually not
Delbert not dead well placed on that
square but it is a temple issue he's
attacking this pawn and I have to place
his six as you see and I think you see
right the engine you see yeah
c6 is kind of mandatory I have to do it
there is Ruby 5 and things like that and
now Queen d3 and now this thing is I
felt that g6 is not great because I
thought g4 would happen
g4 I can actually do 97 of course and
then to e6
you know that's stupid of course I saw
that this is just lost em you cannot
play like that getting caught in the
default but 97 is actually ok
because now I have Knight to d6 to block
the whole thing so g6 is better than my
move I went to 96 and then very nicely
played Bishop g5 I have to play a sixer
of 6 and now there is this huge weakness
on the e-file Bishop f4 castles Andrew
p6
super annoying now this is this whole
only six now it seems that night of
seven now was a mistake
but it's not too nice
but this is stronger you look up seven
probably something like that look at
seven if he goes here I mean it's not
nice I don't like my position but maybe
I can
yeah this looks actually bearable if you
can get in Bishop f 897 push this back
it's uncomfortable very uncomfortable
the engine doesn't feel it so bad I mean
if I can expel the book and trade one
care of rooks also I'm totally fine
because it's very sound very solid
structures solid yeah this way it gets
it gets awful my bishop before and now
nicely played Knight h4r just a strong
movement the knight was not great on f3
would be excellent f5 and I cannot play
g5 I thought during the game do 296
right Queen g3 I thought this is also
quite strong because I cannot take and
this is going to be well the engine
finds a mate so it's funny I always
thought and I just thought okay that
cannot work but it has even made him
zombies but in fact I can take Here I am
and this is not so clear because the
bishop can take him that's true
I mean White is probably still better
here because my pieces are not very
coordinated okay but g5 is even better
match with Queen g3 and then I define
even if I go here I can play 95 and that
is a
Wester made on g7 in case of the capture
very nice yeah I played Knight a six
position is already very bad Knight f5
is inaccurate okay
but it's so excellent for white now when
g6 and that he answered nicely with a
three yeah and yeah Bishop takes you
three is inaccurate according to the
engine but it's lost anyway if I take
here you will just take on before and
the result is a disaster this is lost
and my hulking sides busted so I took he
played this immediate check takes 97 and
now nicely played tonight a5 check this
is very nice then I take it there's
Queen g3 and just Bishop g7 and he's
attacking without being material down 57
coming and so on very nice
so King h8 has played and he went rook
to e7
you know just using this tempo if I take
here I think even Queen a5 as possible
it's not necessary just take here and
you win
quincy aid and something like that black
has no moves something ok I went rook c8
and Queen a3 blunder yeah that's
nonsense by the engineer it says and it
says blonde of it it just wins the move
wins
Queenie r3 is a bit a bit quicker but
this is strong enough
I played Knight g5 if I take there is
Korean age 5 and there is no way out the
knight cannot means something no Knight
g5 was taken and now he yeah this a
couple of ways to win
I was thinking during the game this
would win age 5 Queen g3 that was my
train of thought
I hope takes a 5 ok
a bit of blunder them okay he he killed
me with Luke chase Andrew p7 and it's
just data completely over yeah I
resigned the excellent game
excellent game by my white and just was
very well played I think and it's a bit
of a shame that I couldn't really am
that I don't have the life recording
because there was the odd moment where I
was genuinely surprised but I just
didn't have the microphone plucked and
it's just I'm I use this I use this
notebook in my in my room here as you
see it see the room in the background
but I also use it outside to sit sit
there and do some do some writing and so
on and when I put it back in my room I
have to plug the microphone and I just
forgot it and it didn't it does not have
than the other microphone active the the
internal one so anyway I think that was
good a good game to look at even though
it was not life I keep it as a regular
video I think it's it's very much worth
looking at thanks a lot for watching